the stories about being a boss and how I
tried to be a boss in a unique way my
own unique way they didn't go to
business school with the art school but
here I am running a company along with
Sam Jake that employs five to six to
seven more people and a minimum if not
more gonna get really busy if anyone is
able to make an oil painting of this
with the text our founders that's their
dream you can google that you just type
Sam and Nico into Google let's ask
engravers dungeon if they can make us
that but it's gotta be oil oil painting
things I just I'm pointing the knife
away from every North in the package
requests for bills near campers is
immunity for clan Greg you're gonna make
me cry yeah tell me this is oil paint
tell me it says our founder
Elliott says our founders on it
[Music]
you're grabbing at those yesterday from
the shelf I had a bunch of props set on
top of them which I try to avoid whole
bunch of gunk on them like water has
been tripping on them from the room
above I'm the other unit so I didn't
build things up hopefully they're not
warped or rotted or anything like that
very sad if they were this belonged to
uh my dad's uncle family heirloom and
all that this one I just got a new day
this is my favorite shirt ever okay I
say this every single month attend a
limited sale once again for this month
having it again this is one of my
favorite shirts
I was thinking hey you know it's about
time we have a cool like metal shirt or
our D&D style corridor digital shirts it
was actually designed by Dustin Peterson
he's an incredible designer look them up
it's really cool he's finally designed
literally the exact I don't know what's
going on here but we were talking about
the origins of corridor digital and I
was talking about how when Nico and
myself we're driving through the
mountain pass coming out to LA saw the
word corridor as in this corridor
through the mountains and he was like oh
I got an idea I'll draw like a cool rock
corridor except there'll be a skeleton
dragon looking over the whole thing and
I was like okay you know what I think I
think you get me like really undersea he
touched me and I was like yes that's
exactly what I'm thinking
print is very heavy-duty got these
really fashionable little sleeve prints
here yeah I know apparently it's a hip
thing these days yeah the kids the kids
with their fidgets betters and they're
dabbing they also you also like the
sleeve prints look on sale right now for
10 days and if you think you'll ever
want to wear this in your lifetime it's
probably worth picking it up right now
you won't have many other chances in the
future and by many others I mean zero no
I only know like one dad joke and it's
what happens when the past present and
future walk into a bar things get a
little tense
visiting my wife's family last week and
they're asking me about what I do for a
living do very unique thing for a living
running YouTube channel I'm lucky enough
to have enough support from all of you
that is it it's not only just me here
but it's a whole team of people people
support our channel through things like
watching sharing our videos buying our
merch supporting us on patreon for
example all these things contribute to
us being able to run this channel
Natalie Sami myself having a living but
Jake Carmichael Nick Christian Ren Gabe
all of us are able to eat and rent our
apartments buy video games because of
you guys so thank you I digress
and I was talking to them about an issue
that we had the VFX punji fell behind
schedule it honestly wasn't up to the
quality that it's expecting at least
initially
time schedule and under quality tells me
there's some issues so I need to fix it
you talk to the team but what I've
discovered is if you've just approached
people and you're yell at them like this
could be better you [ __ ] it up you
should do better like we'd say it nicer
but the message is still the same that
doesn't get your results maybe for a day
or two people work harder if you're
staring over their shoulder that's not
how I do things here I need people to be
motivated I need people don't want to do
the best if you have people wanting do
the best you're going to get good
results but you're not going to get
people to want to be the best if you
yell at them and tell them they're doing
a bad job so I need to get the VFX team
to change their working style change
their attitudes and be motivated and do
that rather than going up them and tell
you what they did wrong I need them to
tell me
what they did wrong because change comes
from inside the person that wants to
change you can put outside pressure on
somebody they might flex a little bit
but if I want them to give it the best
and make that stuff shine just I can try
and make those shine they'd be the ones
discover and explain and change the
mistakes that are causing them to fall
behind schedule and fall behind the
quality level I set in the first place
yeah tell me this is oil paint tell me
it says our founders
[Music]
it does say our founder he looks like
you finished it you just like it's like
in ancient Egypt when the Christians
came and scratched out all the faces of
all the Pharaohs great Craig you you son
of a gun you did it did it great request
to do it I'm not gonna lie that's pretty
good I mean I almost say I won't say
like I almost challenge anyone out there
to do better than I challenge anyone out
there to do better than that read teach
Peter Peter teach read Jake don't words
channels dear God keep them separate so
you might keep editing d keep note
Brandon keep developing Nick make sure
no one dies Spencer keep those servers
running Christian do the best business
you can do Gabe keep that amazing
concept that going Steve don't kick them
out just keep and I'm drinking booze
that Street made guys sent us
come on cameraman hey did you know that
we're professional pubsey players we're
going through a tournament this weekend
and we are going to professionally play
some player unknowns battlegrounds isn't
that cool the only way we're going to
win is with your support we'll see how
it goes it's only the best pub G players
in the world are going to be there we're
going to a pub G tournament and because
of that the best players in the world
are going to a pub G tournament this
weekend they happen to be different
people us and the best players but we
will both be there
what is this tournament you may ask well
it's the 10 gig festival in Chattanooga
Tennessee and we are going out there to
play some pub G with our boy shonduras
against the best players in the entire
world I don't know how I feel about that
I feel like I'm I'm a pretty good player
I won my first chicken dinner last night
two nights ago last week but it's given
me the confidence to go there and
compete from 3:00 to 7:00 p.m. Eastern
Saturday - and apparently on Saturday as
well come and join us here in the area
or want to play some pub G if you're not
there's a livestream on Saturday and
Sunday 3:00 to 7:00 p.m. Eastern both
days 10 gig festival calm yeah it's
gonna be pretty cool I'm really excited
I've never professionally played in a
tournament before I've never
competitively played that is so let's
see if we become professionals maybe
maybe I can add that to the old resume
professional pub G player I like the
sound of that I play video games for a
living I was explaining to these
frustrations to Ivy's family how I was
going to fix them and you know the XP
was like what are you do is like well
there's always things that play because
I try to be understandable
I try to be empathetic and I try to also
hold people to certain expectations a
team needs a manager if you have people
working with you on something they need
something to lead them to how to do it
but what I don't want to spend my time
doing is checking up on them and making
sure it's all happening I want somebody
to put in the effort and have the desire
to do the best damn job they can so I
just family asked me like how did I
learned that where did that come from
and that actually really made me pause
because I didn't learn it in the class
anywhere and it's just something I had
an innate sense of when I started doing
this part it's going for my father who
runs some businesses and talked about
the challenges he faced
I guess those lessons kind of stuck with
me or at least those challenges he was
dealing with people do things for a
reason and if you can understand why
they do things and approach them on that
level it's so much easier to connect
with somebody it leads to actual change
and at least me not having to be there
to then stare over your shoulder every
day like a teacher that's not how people
work that's really not respectful the
people around you and you gotta you
gotta just push them you gotta push them
to to tell you what's going on and you
can't take [ __ ] I think the only
[ __ ] that would come from this is if
somebody was working here who didn't
quite want to be here and just had to be
here too for a paycheck which we are in
a position where it's never really been
the case when somebody works with us at
court or they work with us because they
want to be here everybody here wants to
be here at any point somebody can leave
I don't want them to I like them they're
all here they're amazing at what they do
but I'm not gonna force somebody to stay
and I'm not gonna dangle money over them
to make them stay money is only only go
so far as a motivator like at the end of
the day people need to want to do what
they're doing you're gonna be here
you're here because you want to be so if
you're slacking off and you clearly
don't want to be here and you should
leave and that just that attitude
changes things so significantly [ __ ] I
should have been recording clean now I'm
done cleaning them Porsha this excecute
has some water damage is there a place
you can bring to get it fixed or better
clean probably do you see that that
cloudiness yes you see like the scratch
right here these chunks are here what's
coming off I can't tell if that was like
scratched lacquer or it's like dunk
that's built up it's just all-purpose
cleaner I can't imagine this damaging a
freezin soft vinyl varnishes [ __ ] I
start the conversation by asking them
how many tras did you get done a day how
many shots do you think you should be
able to get done a day does that number
line up with an hour you gave me some
line up with reality probably won't I
know my shots I got done a day and I
know how many shots they think they can
get done a day but Shh
that's not that's not for me to say it's
for them to say yeah some why why didn't
those shots get done
why wasn't on schedule what needs to
change and I let them copy the answers